here we go towards the night before
christmas
john travolta is showing off his holiday
spirit i'm excited for everyone here to
see it and who wouldn't be excited to
see this moment the actor shared this
special video to instagram on christmas
day with his kids ella and benjamin
snuggled up in bed travolta begins to
read a visit from saint nicholas closing
with a holiday message
here we go towards the night before
christmas
she was during christmas
roasting merry christmas everybody and
this was just the latest festive video
from the actor
[Music]
on christmas eve travolta shared this
sweet montage providing a glimpse into
how their family spent the holidays
[Music]
stages of our lives
ella posted the same clip to her
instagram writing quote christmas is
almost here and i'm still 14 years old
and a weird girl at heart and the
travoltas have plenty to celebrate this
year last month the proud dad praised
ella for the release of her upcoming
[Music]
episode the aspiring singer shared this
snippet of one of the songs off the
album
i guess bill was fired when he wrote
that song
i know that she's your light
[Music]
[Music]
in the comments travolta wrote
i'm so very proud of you ella it's
amazing you're thrilled dad
of course this isn't ella's first foray
into the family business it's as
exciting as it gets following news that
ella was cast in a feature adaptation of
alice in wonderland back in july
john took to instagram with praise he
wrote quote here's my daughter ella
starring in a live-action reimagining of
alice in wonderland called get lost i'm
a very proud dad
i'm ridiculous i'm behind the camera
mouthing every
word she says and after co-starring in
the poison rose in 2019 john and ella
stopped by the talk where he admitted to
being a very hands-on parent he would
come up in between scenes because i was
in a car so he would come in
that was great oh my gosh oh sorry okay
good
you